I have decided in 2020 to run for
president
Kanye West is making good on that
promise from the 2015 MTV Video Music
Awards and now President Donald Trump is
weighing in I feel like I have a
responsibility in an interview with Real
Clear Politics Tuesday Trump said that
if the rapper actually does run for
president this year he would have to
view it as a trial run for 2024 noting
that because the election is just four
months away it could be hard for him to
get on the ballot in many states but a
source tells ET there's no ifs about it
he's quote 100% planning on running the
world to be a better place it's
important to note that as of Wednesday
Kanye is not currently registered as a
candidate with the Federal Election
Commission after announcing his bid for
president in a tweet on the 4th of July
alongside the hashtag 20/20 vision
regardless Trump doesn't seem too
worried about the competition describing
the whole thing as very interesting yeah
biggest understatement of the decade
anyway Trump who's had a pretty friendly
relationship with Kanye over the years
also added that the a-lister has a real
voice this is one that proved it I could
be President oh he has a voice alright
in a new interview with Forbes the
fashion mogul opened up about his
presidential run explaining quote like
anything I've ever done in my life I'm
doing to win and get this Kanye who has
famously donned a maggot in the past
says he no longer supports Trump quote I
am taking the red hat off with this
interview during the four-hour long
wide-ranging interview
Kanye also revealed that he would run as
a Republican if the president drops out
or as an independent if he does not the
rapper admitted he's never voted before
he also believes that he had the
coronavirus back in February and said
vaccines are the mark of the beast
as for his running mate Kanye said he
selected Michelle did ball a preacher
from Wyoming oh and he envisions a White
House organ
a tional model based on the fictional
country of Wakanda in black panther and
while a lot of people don't know what to
do with all of that myself included
his wife Kim Kardashian is backing him
1,000% in life what I've learned is you
just kind of have to go with it a source
tells et that Kim is unwavering in her
support of Kanye and loves that he isn't
afraid of what people think of him I've
seen him go through a lot and he's just
the most genuine person and you know he
might say things that might get
misinterpreted and people don't see the
context behind it but I always know his
heart
[Music]